I am just very excited Bernie Sanders
the independent senator from Vermont
can't stop talking about Medicare for
all which he says will finally solve all
of America's health insurance problems
in fact creating a national single-payer
plan is a truly terrible idea that will
likely bankrupt the country drive down
the rate of health care innovation and
not even really improve health outcomes
established in the late 1960s Medicare
is the nation's health insurance program
for people 65 and over it's also the
single biggest driver of the national
debt payroll taxes and premiums paid by
beneficiaries to cover less than half
the program's cost which are expected to
double from 700 billion dollars a year
to almost 1.4 trillion dollars a year
over the next decade Sanders has
proposed a new payroll and income tax to
pay for his plan but it's not at all
clear that such hefty new taxes would
come close to covering its cost that's
because we have no idea what the bill
will actually come to but this much we
do now his home state of Vermont pulled
the plug on a less generous plan that
would have raised taxes even more for
all the problems with the US healthcare
system it sets the pace for innovation
and new treatment options in a way that
no single-payer system on the globe does
that's because innovators here can
expect to earn back the cost of
developing new treatments in a way
that's foreclosed by most single-payer
systems they inevitably come with all
sorts of price controls that discourage
new products and services and they also
ration access to the same does having
health insurance mean you'll be
healthier that's the implicit promise of
Bernie Sanders Medicare for all program
and Obama care too but surprisingly the
evidence for this is thinner than you
might think the two big studies on the
length between having insurance and
actual health suggest that merely having
insurance doesn't lead to better
outcomes for the vast majority of people
having insurance can relieve financial
and emotional stress but it's not
exactly clear that it will leave you
physically better off all of which makes
the case against expanding Medicare to
all if single-payer couldn't even make
it out of Bernie Sanders Vermont
there's no reason at all to try it on
all of America
you